si tenemos dos funciones que se están
multiplicando por ejemplo f x x gx y
queremos sacar la derivada con respecto
de x de esta nueva función que conforma
la multiplicación de estas dos funciones
o sea de la función
f por g de x entonces lo que tenemos lo
que vimos en uno de los vídeos pasados
la regla del producto es que eso es
igual a la derivada de fx por la función
g sin derivar más
efe de x la función tal cual por la
derivada de g ok en cada uno de estos
términos tenemos una función derivada y
la otra no y después cambiamos la
función que estaba derivada aquí ya no
va estar derivada entonces esa es la
regla del producto lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo es formular la regla del
cociente que en realidad sale
directamente de esta regla del producto
pero en muchos libros de cálculo y en
sus clases le van a llamar la regla del
cociente la verdad yo siempre me olvido
de cuál es la regla y la vuelvo a sacar
de esta regla del producto
porque es muy sencillo y en realidad
nada más es otra forma de expresar esta
regla tal vez en alguna ocasión si te
sirve hacer algunos cálculos más fácil
si te sabes tal cual la regla del
cociente pero en general siempre puedes
deducir la a partir de la regla del
producto entonces veamos cómo se deduce
digamos que tenemos dos funciones
efe de equis y gx que está dividiendo a
efe de equis y queremos sacar la
derivada de esta nueva función la
derivada con respecto de x eso a que es
igual pues realmente el truco es tomar
efe de x y multiplicarlo
por 1 en 13 x aquí ya lo tenemos tal
cual igualito que en la fórmula del
producto pero para hacerlo todavía más
sencillo vamos a escribir ag x de otra
forma uno entre gdx en realidad es igual
a gd x al a menos uno a la potencia
menos uno
y entonces aquí simplemente aplicamos la
regla del producto junto con la regla de
la cadena para este eje x a la menos 1
entonces esto es igual a la derivada de
fx
por qué ve x al menos 1
más s de x por la derivada de gx a la
menos uno ahora aquí vamos a usar la
regla de la cadena sostenemos una cosa
entre paréntesis a elevada a la menos
uno entonces bajamos el menos uno y
tenemos la cosa está elevada ahora al
menos 2 g de x a la menos 2
y multiplicamos por la derivada de lo de
adentro del paréntesis o sea por la
derivada de gx y listo esta es la
derivada de fx entre v x aunque no se
parece a la fórmula de la regla del
cociente que aparece en todos los libros
entonces pues vamos a simplificar esta
ecuación para que se parezca para que
esté igualita a ver esto es igual a f
prima de x se la derivada de equis entre
g de x knights que en realidad es son
menos porque estaba multiplicando por
menos menos
efe x por gx a la menos 2 o sea entre g
de x
al cuadrado porque prima de equis o sea
la derivada de g ya se parece un poquito
más sin embargo todavía le falta la
última en simplificación ok aquí tenemos
dos fracciones y el denominador de ésta
es que de x al cuadrado entonces vamos a
hacer que este denominador también se
hace de x al cuadrado ok tus
multiplicamos arriba y abajo por feve x
por g de x de aquí sale el cuadrado y
ahora sí ya podemos sumar estas
fracciones y nos queda
efe prima de x por gd x
menos este menos de aquí que salió de
aquí de derivar gx a la menos uno
entonces menos fx
por mi prima de x que estaba aquí entre
todo esto entre 9 x
al cuadrado
si se fijan aún así se sigue pareciendo
mucho a la regla del producto o sea
tenemos la derivada de una de las
funciones por la otra función tal cual
sin derivar y luego ahora si hay un
menos en lugar de un más la función que
habíamos derivado en un principio sin
derivar ahora por la otra función
derivada entre la función que está en el
denominador al cuadrado
entonces cada vez que no se acuerdan de
la regla del cociente pueden recordar la
regla del producto
y acordarse que hay que escribirlo como
una multiplicación y usar la regla de la
cadena en este término